大家好
歡迎收看我們今天的榮耀華爾街
今天我們要講三大重點
我們今天畫面不太一樣
是
等一下給大家一個surprise
今天台灣股市大展
哇266點
什麼叫大展
因為很多人覺得跌1000點
對
可是為什麼0050下跌
等一下我一次跟大家講
第二個
中小型股
大展40%
一堆股票展停板
我們的環球金
我們的國具
讓他展就展
有救了嗎
可是韓國股市今天大跌
5%
怎麼會這樣
危機解除了嗎
今天講到這個東西
台股最近震很凶對不對
真的震很凶
為什麼震很凶
因為一會跌破4萬點
跌破了4萬點以後
哇不好意思
哲哲買了1億0050
馬上上漲了1000點
哇上漲了3000點
每個人都說
哇1億0050
賺1000萬
哲哲好厲害啊
哇那不好意思
那台股關股是今天震更凶啊
本來很多人說跌1000點
我說會上漲
很多人不相信哲哲
結果哇真的今天又上漲了
可是除此以外
臉書卻都是我
可聽說有一個人比我更有名
哇
韓國的吹傘
聽說他也跳一個什麼
正胸
不是台古正很胸
正胸舞
我哪知道什麼叫做
台古的正胸舞啦
來
Music
上
是不是 這叫正胸舞
大家 欸你知道Live很累
壓力很大
我們剛才有沒有跳個快100次
我知道單分析師不好單啦
好不好
我就要下去
去問那個畫面解盤
我不知道節奏有沒有對
Key的節奏還可以嗎
沒問題
我們要切這個畫面
我跟你講
這個就不是AI了好不好
那個一般的畫面
可能人家YouTube撿很多次
我們是Live直播
讓人家騙不了人
我不知道大家喜不喜歡
這個單分析師
我剛才跳這個舞
我平常買股票不會發抖
跳舞
這這好緊張
這不是重點啦 我看今天又爆了
我們來看一下大家閃物有什麼問題
來來來
那依依剛才OK嗎
OK
節奏我對嗎
有 好帥
真的嗎 笑死我了
火師不錯
這只有在正版 沒有正嗎
真的嗎
有啦
有啦 你們不要這樣子
我啦 我
好啦 洗完喊一下口號
發生什麼事情
你們需要洗版的這樣子嗎
對啊
有沒有傳奇傳財經中心節目
對啦 可以再久一點
不行了 我這邊已經在抽金了 你知道
對啊
好啦好啦 你們畫面崩得很快
好不好
還是分析股票也
桌子沒了 桌在這邊啦
總會沒了 好不好
好啦 謝謝大家
今天整個爆掉了
今天直播人數
前面沒有看到人真的很可惜
是不是 今天直播人數
紫紫沒有動
有嗎
莉莉 沈德我沒有動嗎
我剛才是有吧
胸肌 這樣好不好
這樣好不好
有啦
不是 因為剛才節奏比較難 好不好
我已經努力了 好不好
身體很僵硬
你不知道我從小到大沒在跳舞了
我還讀書打電動 好不好
OK嗎 好啦 就這樣子啦
沒關係啦 你們不喜歡我也沒辦法啦
這次已經努力了
來 反正做什麼事
我都經歷到最好
我們本來還叫Lily要去買鼓圍對不對
要把她打在鼓圍
是
結果買不到
到處都買不到
買不到
沒辦法
台灣學醫院的人真少
我們已經跑到台北市
全… 跑到新北市
跑到如都去了 你知道嗎
你知道嗎
結果還是沒有買不到
OK嗎
好啦 那就是這樣子吧
那我們來看一下今天股票
來 那個你們看到我們五大透的跌
我說台積電為什麼跌
今天台灣股市展台積電為什麼跌
因為我們有講這個溢價對不對
我們有講 來我們看一下
溢價 什麼叫溢價
我說過禮拜五是不是台積電展停
但紅海沒展停啊
五大全值股裡面
不是五大全值股
前五大全值股
紅海沒展停
然後台達電沒展停
我說過你說國文英文數學
物理化學
五顆裡面
我說你平均100分
你四顆100分
一顆99分
你不能說你平均100分
你只要一顆沒有100分
就不能說平均100分
結果台灣股市昨天100分
暫停板所死
我講的是
那個台灣50
台灣50是個加權權重
所以代表是
這個是議價多漲了
所以今天把它拉回
我們講在前面
有啊
你怎麼找到這樣的分析師
我是真的預告在前面
真的
但分析師不好當
還要預告未來
還要練身體
我哪天要唱歌
我們要唱歌
要跳舞
這把年紀的真的是
還要重訓
深蹲
真的
真的好不好
很辛苦喔
找到只得這樣多才多藝
重點是
我跳舞跳得好不好
不是重點
好不好
股票
轉不轉比較厲害啊
各位
好不好
是跟大家講
靠頭腦
我不知道你們是喜歡我的身體
還是喜歡我的財富
還是喜歡我的頭腦
我希望一起喜歡或喜歡我的頭腦
比較重要好不好
只是如果帥爐金城武
結果股票讓你賠錢
你也不想看喔
來來我們來看一下重播
預告在前面
來
我們還說喔
今天有機會翻紅
你們看一下預告
來
那我們看一下
熙熙字幕
重來
來 3 2 1
90%太高
我認為70%
明天跌的幅度會在-300點以內
甚至有機會翻紅
記起來我說的 好不好
為什麼 因為最重要的
亞馬遜的財報是自由現金流量是負的
你看 有機會翻紅
我說亞馬遜財報自由現金流量是負的
代表這個AI泡沫假話題啊
為什麼之前AI
為什麼之前
自由現金的那樣為富的就跌
現在就漲了
是不是你看我預告前面禮拜六啊
你看禮拜六
在加班啊
我穿那麼正式啊來公司啊
今天正式來上班
我穿那麼不正式啊
我第一次穿那麼不正式好不好
以後不會啦好不好
且看且走好不好
看一次少一次
你比較喜歡這個衣服
還在這邊
好啦
來來來先跟大家講
所以你看預告前面
直接講台灣股市漲耶
就我講的五條的好不好
不是重點
重點是台灣股市漲
這時候預告在前面
這跟大家講
來看一下看一下
看一下哇
約會期待每天哏
你們不要拜託不要期待每天哏
這樣我壓力很大
好啦
來真的翻紅
外資空單八萬八千口
你不要想那麼多
這個拼彈心好不好
謝謝大家
來
提審了
謝謝
來來
我看每個人都看得不錯
來
身體加減喜歡
這樣真可口
謝謝大家
好
來我們看一下
八逆逆百真
很重看直播
你們今天畫面泡得太快了
今天直播人數多少
怎麼都多
今天還有才4000
5000人
那我們來慢慢看一下
扣子可不可以再解一顆嗎
就這樣就好了
不要再解一顆
如果有了
就好了好不好
我們沒有那麼的心三色
到時候
小孩子不宜
看做股票人都18歲以上沒關係
是
來 我們來看一下
你們看一下國劇也拉漲停了
國劇我們今天也恭賀前訊了
我們跟他講喔
國劇在低漲的時候
誰敢公開的買
而且我還第一時間跟你講喔
很多主動型ETF是砍在這一丁喔
訓掉了是不是
然後我還跟大家講
我從現在開始支持00981A
搖遲積母
我說我跟他站在同一陣線
而且我還說
你可以買00981A有沒有看到
有 從長說
我幾次買台灣50喔
我說你可以買00981
但是我說買國具
買黃金可能賺更多
我們在講
有
你們看一下
00981那一天是不是暫停
對不對
禮拜五暫停嗎
今天還漲了3.75%
贏台灣50喔
你真的去哪邊找到這麼好的老師啊
我真的有時候公開送股票給你
我不知道為什麼
因為我會員可以賺更多
我今天把很開心喔
不是我剛才跳舞的節奏
有對了
沒關係
那個我還是很怕一下
因為莉莉是音樂系
我到底看有沒有結這麼對啊
有對啦 有啦
因為我剛才
你知道我這邊已經抽筋了
我剛才錄影前
前十分鐘還結做得一直不對
沒有 頭長練了
然後頭上往後還要很酷
你做什麼
頭長練得很認真啦
我真的練得很認真
超過你們想像
我練到太認真
覺得我不像分析師
我還是看一下股票好了
不過只有練今天跟昨天晚上一天
兩天
我真的練很認真
你應該沒有想像
我會練得那麼認真吧
對啊
從來沒有看過
從來沒看過 我本來就很認真
跳舞啦 跳舞啦
跳舞從來沒有看過
因為我沒有底子啊 好不好
是跟大家講
做什麼事都要認真
那我要告訴他 股票才是我
其實很多人天分是會跳舞唱歌
那是天分
我天分在做股票 你知道嗎
所以我做股票
就算隨便做都可以贏別人
更何況我是很認真做股票的
所以很多人說 哇
買1億的台灣50 正很兇
可是我就敢買
所以我今天反而很開心
台灣50回答我反而很開心
為什麼
所以我根本不在乎我賺多少錢
沒關係 反正我賺的錢
我還是要捐部分出去
我不知道什麼在不在乎
得知我命不得我信
我就說跌4萬點
我跌破4萬點我就要怎麼樣進產啊
沒有跌破呢
就當作沒這回事嘛
你們賺錢啊
所以禮拜四我親切很差
你知道什麼
因為很多人數我台灣50有賺錢
可是股票跌停
啊 則股票跌了
請問你們今天有什麼好講的
你們今天有講一句話
則跳往下還好
你們不要跟專業無則比嘛
你們跟分析師比
可能我已經不錯了
我們沒有攻擊分析師
我是覺得各個分析師
我都愛他們 好不好
大家都認真的
批評分析師也不會賺了錢
我還在重申一次
我們那天不是會小心頭套嗎
對
我不是要批評別的分析師
做控分析師
我們大家都好朋友 好不好
除非一直針對者者
不然我真的欺負者太兇
我才會回籍
回籍就是很兇猛的
該提告提告
不然我講的是同業
萬一我們不要太誇張
我都可以接受 好不好
這跟大家講
因為其實批評分析師到最後業績也不會好
這個都有例子的
好扯遠的來我們來看一下
我還是要講喔
國具今天是不是你看
所以00980A搖瓷金母是不是買什麼
是不是買這個股票
是不是買國具
你看最近績效就很好啦
那個買國具我們看一下重播
國具那時候跌停板喔
國具是之前天天沒有人要喔
斷手斷腳
接用手接斷手用腳接斷腳
只有郭子龍我跟妳講的
我對你很好喔
我那天國巨的時候我說500
507元我說我這邊開始進產有沒有
我講實在話
隔天我們還可以買到
有人如果運氣好還可以買到400多塊你知道嗎
最低450
我在這邊跟你講你可以接最低
我在這邊講你可以接最低
我什麼時候叫你買國巨
我告訴你我國巨這一段賺錢啦
300到600多元這一段啦
這一段啦
賺錢啦
後面我就說開始小心了
跌的時候要跌很快
我家要漲就漲 國際
我家要漲就漲 我家要跌就跌
我家要反彈 馬上反彈 我家要暫停就暫停
你告訴我哪個老師人家怎麼這樣
我們說實在話
我不去施厚話 我不去馬歐泡啊
我們是靠頭腦鍋的意思
所以投資廟
你要就是要我這樣分析師啊
我會救多少人的國際啊
我要不是我進場買
然後這樣可能姚慈欣母
可能同意的也看到我的
其他投信也看到我的
欸不好意思低膽進場
你看能不能一直跳扣進
跳扣嗎
不行啦
春聯製作所好像沒展20%
台灣就籌碼面問題嘛
唉
所以我跟大家講喔
你記得一件事情
我講得很清楚
我當初是不是講800元以上有賣壓
800元以下隨便談
有沒有講
有
你這邊可以賺300元可以賺60%
你可以賺300元是不是
來看一下不用放大革新
在這邊攢一次800元
有賣壓在這邊賺300元有沒有來喔再看一下喔
這邊賺300元
在這邊
如果下去
再來一次
再賺300元
你知道嗎
再賺300
因為創新高很難啦
不要騙自己
再下去一次再賺300元
你3次300元
但低點我來處理喔
我教你怎麼樣
要到並出
你要找一個老師真的解決你的被動元件啊
你有被動元件你來找我啊 投資廟
我跟你講跳舞不是專家
如果你覺得跳舞我很厲害 我告訴你
我連跳舞都很認真 我告訴你
股票我才專家啦
我才專家專家 重心我也不是專家
雖然身材還算OK 那都不是我的專家
我真正專產什麼
股票 我叫他長就長
我叫他跌就跌
你知道嗎
我告訴你你到時候來個三次900元
你什麼股票都解套了啦
國際解套備動員就解套
你備動員就不找我你找別人喔
那些人就害你賠錢了
你不找我你找誰
我跟你說認真的你不找我你找誰
今天反彈99專案你趕快找我好不好
這個你要不要沒關係已經很多人要了好不好
反彈3399有沒有
真的才399好不好
你不找我找誰好不好
這些股票都是一樣
我們這個都是一樣
我們剛才國際從不外面播嘛對不對
國去
那個E 國去還沒播嘛對不對
還沒
還沒 我們來播一下
那你看國去的傳播
再一次喔
我其實
我其實還是比較喜歡穿西裝啊
那個小航跟那個E
強烈要求我
那個
要脫掉西裝好不好
來 我們看 我覺得很多股票都這樣
我們看 3 2 1
股票是這樣 國劇也殺過頭了
今天又在各地諜聽辦
國劇有進產啦
不要再說我罵00981A啦 好不好
好不好 我現在跟00981A的那個搖慈金母
我搖慈金母之前跟有人說我罵他 沒有
我支持你
我跟你講啦
我說甚至你現在可以買00981A
如果你不知道什麼時候要買 什麼要買
我做人很公道啦
我做人不拗人家 打聽我郭忠為人
我做人很公道 我不拗人家
不要之前說我一直ㄉㄧㄧㄥ
我跟你講
如果是一個大多位行情
可以買什麼
主動是ETF
空頭行情那就不行了
所以你們現在了解吧
你看空頭行情它是不是跌很快
是
大家發現
喔 原來姊姊說的是對的
原來怎麼樣
原來喔
主動型ETF
以前是漲很兇
跌也跌很兇
有沒有知道
這是主動型ETF有沒有
對
已經漲很兇有沒有
跌也跌很兇
所以只有大多頭的時候可以買
你分不及什麼大多頭什麼大空頭
就不要買了
有沒有知道
有沒有知道空頭的時候
台灣50更沒什麼跌有沒有看到
有
前面這邊是輸人家啦
對不對 沒錯吧
前面左邊輸人家啦
098年那時候很會漲
右邊是跌很少啦
贏人家很多有沒有
有沒有 右邊有沒有
你家是不是跌很慘
可是你反彈的時候有沒有彈的比台灣56塊
有沒有看到
有
我都把特性告訴你了
我說我不傲人家的
該念00981又念
該幫忙他
我就幫忙他
開心
國具喔
800元
我先講目前啦
我去800元
那個是一個
很漂亮的一個滿足價格
那會不會上1200
我且戰且走
我只說800元以下
基本上你很容易閉著眼睛做多賺錢
那者者我知道啦
我明天做進場
我不管你
你兩根斬停百
你在進場
誰叫你不每天看我節目
我是在那邊看我跳舞才進來
不是看我買1005才進來
我告訴你啦 那都來不及了
是不是 你看到新聞報導
再看來不及
鐵粉是怎麼樣
所謂的鐵粉是這樣子
台灣股市
在沒有破4萬點的時候對不對
我是不是說破4萬點我就進場
沒錯吧
有 沒錯
這邊我已經暗示了
隔天破4萬點
你就可以跟我進場了
你不相信
當我劍爆了
我節目上也講的
網路上討論我了
這跟十字K
你也可以怎樣
在進場啊
禮拜四啊
沒錯
當天你還沒看我節目
你就知道我一定進場
因為你知道我信守承諾
隔天
你不相信我
我已經確定了
我還可以看
我9A9J永峰版信的券3帳號
我沒有秀出帳號
因為不能秀
我要遵守主管機關跟我的約定
是
因為我太紅了
真的太紅了
我就不秀了
然後呢
可是我可以跟你去查
券3有沒有進出
這知道吧
沒錯
你看那個加起來1130
然後永夢版新還有那麼多人買
對不對
買0050
隔天你就可以跟我一起進場了
我也跟你發誓了
我說如果我有造假
永夢版新的
來抓到我造假
我給他1億
你是永夢版新的
如果我說的話
你會幫我保留這幻化好不好
當然不會啊
當然不會 我可以賺1億耶
是不是我可以賺1億
為什麼不要
所以你看
我買1億台灣50
馬上賺了
賺上去以後
是不是拉起來
唉
你每次都失后
可是拉起來以後
你已經少一個最好買點了
你少賺1000萬了
我一一就賺1000萬了
所以我真的很好
我這一波整個完全
你所有話題也好
股票也好
ETF也好
我自己賺到錢也好
但我最想要是
會給你們賺到錢
我愛你們
我在講一件事情
我大可偷偷買
我不要有壓力啊
你不要覺得整個在炫富啊
我不要跟大家講
為什麼
我是抱著風險啊
你知道如果破底了
多少人會笑我
100多萬粉絲
還有不認識我的
基本上沒有人不認識我了好不好
他們會笑我 知道嗎
這事情想想看
你要長分析師
其實我是真的很想穿西裝
我有點害羞
來
所以這一波真的很準
這車好帥 謝謝你們
我們今天給女粉 男粉開心一點
來
我是外圓堅 環球金
為什麼開高走低
因為就是處置害的
3532台勝科
有沒有看到
今天還在處置
今天是不是有新聞報導什麼
來
台勝科跌
那是不是會影響環球金
會
是不是
環球金禮拜五已經有一個暫停了嘛
那今天至少是暫嘛
你知道嗎
台勝科跌為什麼
因為處置啊
處置真的不好啦
我不知道是因為英雄所見念頭
因為很多人在討論
然後還是
這節目大家看了覺得哇去反應
有人去跟立委反應啦好不好
那我真的覺得說不過去
你說展要處置沒關係
讓大家冷靜一下
跌幹嘛要冷靜一下冷靜
你跌你不斷大戶中十戶
你還要逼人家
去哇我現金買股票
還用現金買股票
然後先存到一定的專戶裡面
才能買股票
不是這樣搞吧
每個國家都是要增加流動性
只有我們台灣
這麼奇怪的特性
不能說台灣特有
我覺得這兩碼子事情
你時刻去問9個散戶
都覺得這是不對的制度
晚上漲
我覺得晚上要處置我沒有意見
好不好 因為散戶有時候會追
晚下
台股跟股市晚下跌
你不能用跌幅來處
然後它已經跌幅還沒有量
不能了
你看是不是我講了以後
好像大家也反應了
我不知道是不是我啦
因為網路上也蠻多人討論的
我覺得有影響
可是我也不想去扛這個話題
免得有影響
大家覺得我帶頭
我沒有 我們要做這個事情
可是我覺得
好的話題可以去討論 你懂得意思嗎
對的事情我們大家可以去做 好不好
來 先跟大家講
你看喔 有沒有
股民哭喊
股票大跌到也賣不掉
立委完事件說
30年制度嚴重脫節 有沒有看到
近期接貨大量股民陳情
是真的沒錯 流動性不行
你看哪有聯發科在可以處置的
華新科也是被處置啊
是不是
拜託
華新科也被處置是怎樣
是不是這不對啦 是不是
你看一根這種
有水平線就知道他是被處置的
這不對你知道嗎
近期很多人在反應
我覺得這個是
這反應我覺得該反應要反應
讓大家不要激動
這是對的政策
讓國主黨的機關在改變制度之前
一定會有時間
好不好
他們做的事情也很忙
是跟大家講
這個我讓大家都讓台灣更好
沒什麼不好
他就說 這我就不多說了
他就說 他覺得分盤制度是過時
因為處罰之前的
那現在是壟斷機制
這是用現在盤中的
好不好
檢討處置機制
我覺得重點是跌
不應該有流動性的限制
好不好 這是重點
我覺得其他的
我不針對對跟錯
那講不完
到底是處置制度比較好
還是壟斷制度比較好
問題是你不應該在股票跌的時候
還用它儲值
這才重點
你可以漲的時候要儲值
我沒意見
你要不要輪動我沒意見
跌的時候不應該
你知道那時候
哇還有漲停板反正17%
金融海嘯的時候變成
一半就跌停板
什麼意思
3.5%就跌停板
你聽過嗎
就3.5%就漲停板
3.5%跌停板
金融海嘯的時候很慘
那就變成很多股票很容易跌停
你有看到台積電日月灣都跌停嗎
沒有對不對
我看過
所以我跟你講我跌破4萬點
我根本沒有感覺
現在賺1000多萬我沒感覺
今天拉回1%啦
大概900萬吧
不用幫我算好不好
我自己算一下
我算一下我賺多少錢
畫面那個
OK嗎
不要切喔
對戰檔喔
不是對戰檔是
好現在不能看這個損益
不重要那應該900萬
我沒有在乎那個錢好不好
理論上我要5、6萬點
我在做好不好
那現在台子期
喔 台子期現在又跌300點怎麼看
我要說實在的話好不好
我不是今天看到盤後的
台灣股市今天有點多展
可是台灣股市至少確定一件事
上規指數至少有機會不要破底
你聽懂嗎
韓國股市
韓國股市這個底不能再破
記得我實話
一定要記得
大家看一下喔
看一下喔
看一下
韓國股市什麼底
就是它上禮拜五不是大漲嗎
就是那個槓桿ETF
哇 增加這個保證金過後
開始反彈的前一個低點
不能跌破
記得計畫
韓國股市今天
今天漲15%回
這是韓國股市
漲15%對不對
這邊低點5262點不能跌破
我記得我這句話
526不能跌破
今天大漲15%
然後再回檔個45%
很正常喔
OK嗎
知道我說什麼
來
看一下
很正常
從我看韓國股市最後跌5.13%
所以台灣股市今天算很強
因為台灣股市是紅的
所以明天跌我覺得很正常
我覺得明天跌很正常
因為韓國股市比想像中
台灣股市如果預期的強
可是韓國股市比我想像中弱
如果明天韓國股市再跌
那會什麼啊
會一起拖累台灣股市
所以明天跌的機率比較高
你看我很恐怖喔
我說漲就漲
我說3萬9以下是買一點
就馬上漲停板
台灣股市漲停板
台積電漲停板
台灣50漲停板
我告訴你今天台灣50
可能跌的機率比較高
今天台灣...
什麼你看
今天是不是台灣50跌
是
很恐怖喔
可是今天台灣50跌
最恐怖的是今天台灣50跌
可是台灣台股是漲的耶
台灣股市漲的漲的
漲的一百六十六點有沒有看到
你有沒有覺得我很恐怖
真的
我還知道台灣股市漲
可是台灣五十可能跌
我都預告到前面的人
我還告訴你明天跌的機率有點大
那明天跌的機率略大
情況是要幹嘛
拉回做多
我並不認為會跌破十萬點了
所以你只要有跌你趕快進場但是我並不認為會跌破十萬點你只要有跌你就趕快進場所以你看為什麼你告訴我哪個老師像可以秀出恭喜會員賺錢
只要被動援件的會員
偷偷賺錢
誰會秀都檢去
秀不出來啦
國際今天賺錢552啦
真的啦
哲哲沒跟你開玩笑
秀不出來
我們沒有要批評人家
我們講真的
運氣不錯啦
我真的運氣
跟實力都缺一不可
你越努力 我運氣越好 好不好
真的 你去打聽一下
就連我剛才跳舞
我真的跳到抽筋啊
你問他 我剛才是
沒錯
其實我剛才是不是跳到抽筋
我肚子在抽筋啊
對
真的 因為胸部
你看我平常 OK
這樣可OK
可是剛才那是在身體不要動
胸部要動
不是有胸肌就好了
那個很累
他都往後
真的很難
喔
很難你知道嗎
好不好 我們講
秀一下國具的暫停板
好不好
好
你看國具那天跌停板
我們只用這張圖不好意思
國際跌停板
很慘喔
你看喔
國際跌停板
結果你看
今天恭喜你幫我練一下
畫面給你
好
8月3號星期一
恭喜2327國劇
股價跳空噴出
開盤5分鐘就鎖上漲停
我們上週跌停勇敢進場
馬上就獲利大賺
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續爆
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
你有上車嗎
有跟著投資長嗎
換名給我
來
有沒有跟著投資長
沒有跟著投資長差很多
真的
好不好
股票還是回到腦袋
腦袋才是最重要的
怎麼讓他賺錢
盤感
這是為什麼百萬粉絲
還不是從選股冠軍188%
從以前到現在
沒有人一個人能接近我紀錄
沒有辦法
一記188%
我告訴大家要選10檔股票
10檔股票都暫停
你猜猜看幾%
才10%而已
你們自己去算一下好不好
才10%
對不對
你如果算不出來
你這個算不出來
你就才18%
你有100%
那代表數學還不夠好
我不是嗆你
代表你更需要一個專人
來幫你做股票
應該說給你當一個顧問
股票發展你身上比較安全
來
國際5分鐘手上暫停
真的漂亮
真的漂亮啦
你去想想看
所以我告訴大家
這些股票
阿哲哲哲
阿為什麼不買鴻海
不是嘛
鴻海之前沒什麼跌
所以沒什麼漲
可是有一檔股票
我可能考慮再買喔
連發科
因為連發科
最近說第二個客戶來了
所以真的有機會
TPU晶片
它有機會至少
我不要說它2028年
我明年真的有機會大爆收
因為很多人就跟它生產TPU晶片
這個有暴震
那你就看一下TPU晶片
然後AX一個晶片
一個晶片
就這種專用的晶片
以後會不會智能有機會
會不會智能有機會
注意一下
以後智能會不會有機會
這是重點好不好
這是重點
來
所以這個要注意一下
智能我是覺得連跌都不該
連跌都不該跌
因為根本沒斬跌什麼東西
但它基本面
它現在AI基本面還沒輪到它
好
A是一個晶片
或這種專用晶片
現在台灣比較獨享的
應該說比較真正有收穫的是
連發科
那智能我賭的是
就有點賭啦
有點賭
當然股票
至少你要知道賭的成分多少
我不會說完全重量資源
我應該說我壓保的是未來的爆發
你聽懂 不是現在的
當然如果你要現在的爆發
很多股票還是可以現在的爆發
商量機制精彩
我們說這個本來要創新高股票
跌有沒有真的很扯
我說跌40%以上都可以買了對不對
對
你自己看一下
64 246
這差不多跌40%很扯對不對
你就連續兩根展停板
之前
你有沒有發現到一件事情
國劇跟精彩都是一樣
每天跌停你不敢買
現在每天暫停你反問我要不要買
你們不覺得莫名其妙嗎
就像我的名言
創新高你也不敢買
跌30%你也不敢買
那你趕快退出股市好了
創新高你也不敢追
跌30%你也不敢買
你退出股市
真的真的真的
今天到底怎麼樣
要不要買
人就很奇怪
跌的人也不敢買
現在暫停了
反而這只要不要買
只要不要買
我不敢買
可是我好想買
你們就是這種感覺
我跟你講
我這簡直是AI五眼佛界
來來
這次認真
你不要看我這禮拜
我做很多事情了
我要下載影片
下載影片
你知道C-Dance 2.5嗎
我們看一下
看這影片
等一下
看一下
來 畫面先給我一下
先把它關一下
來 我們看一下
這影片它有C-Dance是2.0跟2.5
有沒有看到
下面是2.0 上面是2.5
它有C-Dance2.0來做
2.5比較多分鏡喔
而且畫面比較連續喔
下面是2.0
上面是最新版本的
都是中國大陸的
AI晶片還不夠喔
還可以這麼厲害喔
如果AI晶片夠
以後我告訴你
為什麼要真人演員呢
所以我說以後要當演員了
真的且慢
除非你非常有特色
你非常努力
不然我不建議
真的我不建議
我不建議就是
至少你要
也不說不建議啊
風險比較高啦
好不好
這樣好像
我不想要嗆人家的夢想
來
等一下
再一次再一次
畫面塊
你看三個字喔
嘴巴張開 聞到
手走出來
然後你看那女生
驚恐的表情機更誇張
上面的
你看到
下面的時間
噴小白布
臉比較假
臉比較深
這結束了
好 這是不錯
2.5
C.Dance
很多人是不是喜歡看
中國的言情的小說
或中國的那個
穿越記或中國的古裝劇
有沒有看
每次這樣子
要不就霸氣總裁
要不就
你看這個女生可能逃出宮外啊
人家逃出宮外要跌倒怎麼辦
你看一下
一個人就救了
你...你是誰啊
快...快幫我下來
那是畫面跟聲音都接得很順
我就是你翻牆也要逃亡的蛇中話
你告訴我 你分不出來真人假人的時候
你就會看AI劇的
不用了啦 老人家現在都不在乎啦
老人家我媽怎麼講
我媽就像我說的
她說沒有我早就看AI劇了
我媽怎麼講 真強者
真什麼然後假強者
你知道之前
你知道嗎
真強者假廢物
真強者假廢物啦
這個你去那個
YouTube找一下
真強者假
真的很強的人啦
真強者假廢物
那根本看不出來
我一看出來是AI
連配角那麼帥我不相信
連配角也那麼美我不相信
連配角 主角配角都漂亮算了
所以跟你講這AI
這個AI只是其中一種運用
像你知道還有一個資料
欸 沒有錯
現在好像已經有好幾種
好像是最新的OpenAI
TradeGPT的下一版本
已經破解了
我之前不是有個87年的數學猜想嗎
是
破解了好多數學猜想啊
之前只有破一個而已啊
好多數學猜想
下一代喔
都瞬間破解
全部解出來了
所以我告訴大家
其實癌症也是一樣
你這些
你這些蛋白質的成分
你怎麼去破解它
怎麼適合它
它就這樣子
以前蛋白質
蛋白質
哇
這種基因鑰匙
你要從裡面幾萬把裡面
你要瞞錯
你要一把一把式
現在不必
你的AI
會跑程式
告訴你模擬這個環境
哪一個藥物是最容易解決這癌症
有些癌症是麻煩的
就算那個肺癌都有好幾種
七八種十幾種的肺癌
腫瘤有好幾十種
雖然肺癌腫瘤有好幾十種
還會突變
還會逃逸
怎麼辦
所以這個時候可能要靠藥物
所以怎麼辦
所以我問你一件事
今天我聽到沈玉琳
之前我們公司某某的尾牙
沒找過他
他說一年的藥錢20萬
他說20萬要拼命工作
那問你一件事
那20萬他要不要付
得付啊
沒辦法
至少他學來有救
以前學來根本就沒什麼救
那20萬
不要說20萬 30萬 40萬
他也會付啊
是不是
這就是沒辦法
如果是我
萬一啦
我媽可能不喜歡甜言之外
我任何人發生這種事
他還是得付
那或者說一般人
不要說付啦
我沒有
我不要說得病
我想不想延年益壽
長壽啊
我多個10歲就好啦
要我花
叫什麼
你問我是1億買台灣物資比較實在
還是1億增加10年的壽命
當然增加10年的壽命
對
有沒有
當然增加10年的壽命啊
是不是
所以我也願意投資啊
很多人願意投資啊
你懂意思嗎
所以你不是說
AI 哎呀看自由的現金流量
我看什麼東西
我不是說
那是一個很好笑的事情嗎
我不是跟2008年一樣
就算什麼什麼營業現金流量為負
笑死人
結果現在亞馬遜反而展了
對亞馬遜反而展了
自由現金流量為負又不在乎了
我說這個亂七八糟
你們多去觀察AI
我告訴你我看的是
我看的是遠方
你不要給我看我地下有什麼東西
有沒有蟑螂老鼠我不在乎啦
所以這些股票通通到時候都會漲
我跟你講你不要到時候五萬點
我跟你講明天有拉回你要用力做多
現在有拉回你要用力做多好不好
真的用力做多好不好
那講話同時又跌幅又熟練了
你有沒有覺得哲哲對你們很好
真的對你們很好啦
沒有像哲哲這樣的人啦
今天我們直播人數有點爆掉
就是爆不是爆
就是有點那個反應有點辣
7000多人算不錯了
來
這責貼圖是你們出的
是我們出的 是我們出的
來
今天走歐巴風 謝謝大家
來我們來看一下另外一個簡訊
精彩
來 幫我唸
好 8月3號星期一
恭喜3374精彩股價跳空噴出
開盤才7分鐘就漲停鎖死
我們買進到現在最高
已經大賺56%
我持續看好他
手上之股獲利續報
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
真的賺大錢你不覺得嗎
是
我精彩真的很敢報
我之前報到100%我沒走
後來掉下去了
你不是可以跟我會員
比較一樣降低成本嗎
那會員
我沒記錯有買的會員都賺錢
所以我跟你講
我真的不是有時候不是要賺
560%你不要找我國總好不好
我黃酒精賺100%我都沒走
我跟你說這個黃酒精真的有機會2000元
我認為啦 不是說一定喔
我們這邊有 我們主管警官有規定我們
但是我們本來股市就沒有一定
所以我問大家一件事情
如果賺這些錢
你賺到怎麼辦
我說你賺到沒關係 你會開心
你賺不到怎麼辦
你明明看到 我問大家一件事
如果再一次4萬點
你真的會跟我一起進展嗎
我覺得莉莉會 一一一會啦
你們會不會
你們還是不會
你們嘴巴說會
再一次恐慌還是不會
或者買一點點
我只問你一件事
現在如果台灣股市會
就會到五萬點到六萬點
明年到六萬點
我認為有機會至少六萬點
請問你現在到底是四萬點買
還是四萬三買有差嗎
沒差
重點是四萬點不一定回得到啊
當然沒有差啊
重點是後面能不能漲嘛
只要有賺錢就好了嘛
你知道我能力
你就該買就買
精彩這邊賺五十六%
他很多股票要漲了啦
真的啦好不好
如果不要整個要漲
納科今天也拉起來了
納科的問題是
怎麼樣
跌太少好不好
所以我說你看群聯
有沒有
群聯今年有沒有看到
也是怎麼樣
8、9、9群聯也快漲停
群聯我覺得比較有看頭啦因為群聯實在跌太深你知道嗎OK嗎只是比較多大戶在藍雅科那沒有關係我藍雅科也賺了快300%
前兩次好像加起來是
加起來204再一次61
如果再負利的話應該是接近300%
這個實在績效你自己看一下
這不能造假喔
我們秀的是普通衛員
我不要秀那種
秀那種你看不到的
特別衛員啊
特別衛員當然是特別的愛給特別的你
來
研發科我們賺了130幾%
因為出兩次啦 好不好
國劇賺了快100%
南亞科賺61%
NO NO NO
南亞科去年初的時候
好像說去年到年初
兩次賺了204%
是
南亞科
我進場就是賺錢
國劇 我也兩進兩出
我打算七進七出
要不要 幫你做加差
所以你有國劇
你有被動元件
你有信倉電
和聲譚 華興科
這些XXX的被動元件
一大堆被動元件族群
你要找我
因為現在被動元件
目前為止
我的績效勝率是百分之百
沒有錯吧
最兩次進場我都進場
都賺錢啊
是
一堆人在國劇
怎麼樣
犧牲慘烈
我在國劇上面笑呵呵
很難算新高
就是因為很難算新高
所以可能只有我能幫你解套
你不找我你也會後悔
有國具的
有記憶體的
你不找我你會後悔
你被套牢了你不找我你會後悔
你現在被套牢了你換股
現在彈兩根斬定板
很多人會彈兩根斬定板
如果你沒有你股票
跌那麼深沒彈兩根斬定板
至少彈一根板
不然你真的很危險問題很大
你還不來找我
你知道我厲害你還不來找我
你要找害你跌的人嗎
你要找讓你買高點的人嗎
問題可大啦
你不要說二者之後我就不管了
我疊三十八不管了 錯
我就說可以做價差
你自己承心自問
你覺得國際人創新高的基多少
短期內高不高 你告訴我
這麼多哀鴻騙眼 你覺得那些人傻瓜
我股成本900塊我通通賣給你
你要買哪個大戶那麼傻啊
直接拉起來 拉起來 拉起來
有可能嗎
這邊套王賣壓都不用理他嗎
這邊套王賣都不用理他嗎
800元以上的
你看看
這邊套好賣樣都不用你他嗎
800元以上套好賣樣都不用你他嗎
不可能嘛
怎麼可以一下子躺在這兒的錢
這個技術分析不是這樣學的啦
你當然這邊傻瓜
我只要問你一件事
假設你有幸1100元
你套1100元喔
我跟你講你只要解套一般人解套就想走了啦
所以1100元會有賣壓
那你覺得1000元不會有賣壓喔
等你幫他拉起來解套
所以不會有人想幫你拉
只有我幫你做價差
不會有人想幫你拉
你趕快來找我 好不好
不論你要取名是反彈99
還價差99
你有這些股票
有記憶體的被動人錢
你趕快找我
因為只有我敢在最低點的時候
買台灣武士
你有沒有覺得我今天反而心情比較好
為什麼
因為我根本不在乎台灣武士
遲早
我認為遲早會賺錢
我認為
可是我最在乎是會員
所以我今天很多會員彈起來
我很開心
知道嗎
那個小男生幾分啊
4E喔
Line的貼圖是我們出的
對我們要不要講
來以後IG就對了
看上IG跟Trade
因為Trade一開始是從IG轉過來的
所以IG跟Trade是同一個帳號
SE718 178
你們知道嗎
OK嗎
SE718 178
有什麼SE718
那假的
好不好
Line是小二手
S718
你這邊看為主
以臉
以什麼
臉書的不要理他
臉書很多假帳號
IG也很多假帳號
踹人都假帳戶
臉書就是這樣子
就是犯了很多詐騙的一段恨行
YouTube不一樣
我們跟Google的關係很好
我們公司跟Google的關係很好
一直有假冒的
我之前怎麼樣
我馬上把它抓下來
影片就可以直接檢舉它了
所以我們記得一件事情
以影片為主
影片講的這幾個帳號為主
其他通通假的
你不知道你打的電話
來電恰起08068085
OK嗎
記者拜託不要打這個了
不要打這個了
算是有民視啊 東森啊 什麼
去EDN是找我
TBS記者科都以後不要把我拍那麼醜
民視都把我拍很帥
可以不要把我拍那麼醜
我講實在話
喔 把我拍得好慘白喔
所以我用化妝
也不要這樣子
喔 民視
東森都給我拍滿帥的
OK
好啦
大家看
這開玩笑遠了
開玩笑的喔
不是開玩笑
別再控單了
不要再控單了
真的不要開控單
這則世界明天好像有法會
法說會啦
開玩笑
法說會嗎
好 我要查一下
治療幫我查一下明年有沒有
好不好 世界經濟也該漲
世界經濟漲 環球經更該漲
世界經濟叫做缺貨 環球經也會缺貨
世界經濟 如果跟環球經拿細經源
你覺得記憶體不用拿 也要拿
你不知道這是齁 我常常跟你講
你要知道這是 OK嗎
來 現在幾分呢
43了 6196帆軒也是一樣
你們自己看一下 6196帆軒
強烈軒的問題是跌太少
你知道嗎
我現在對跌太少股票沒興趣
他很快就創新高了啦
可是我現在知道新位元
新朋友們讓他賺錢
好不好
就是讓他買低股票
微星也沒什麼好講的
微星的問題就是沒有跌啊
所以他現在沒什麼漲啊
微星很快就創新高了好不好
你們想要那種最強制股的
哇強制動能股的
哇就最強的
那我跟你講
微星就是你現在最想要的股票
好不好
再來就是
凡宣就沒什麼動啦
精彩也有機會
記得我說這些東西好不好
我不去吃歐瓦
我也不去馬後跑
該講就講
所以你看喔
台灣股市我說今天會翻紅
哪個老師敢講
你告訴我哪個老師敢講嘛
在禮拜六誰加班
加班人真的不多了啦
都大部分是我們某個分析師
加班以後告訴你
你今天有機會漲
你告訴我誰
上禮拜四
在崩盤的時候
我說拜託你們
再給這
我知道很多人你們以後會愛我
只要跟著我
再給指責最後一次
愛我的機會
愛指責的機會
我是不是講得很清楚
是
你們不理我啊
我也說過了
命一條衝就對了
怕什麼
不論長
創新高你也不敢追
我敢追拉回30%你也不敢買
你真的當我財經綜藝節目喔
你拜託一下
不要再給我結這一段喔
不要當財經綜藝節目
真的我是
我講這些跳舞
我是伯駿一下
可是要讓你記得我中心核心點是什麼
股市中央景要創新高
你要用立買啊各位
用立買啊
我是真的很激動耶
你知道
去香港你要專門飛機師好不好
我不去吃的話 我也不去買後泡啦
哪有跌破的時候 公開買一億的 壓力那麼大
是不是 還要去湊錢 還要公開買 我私底下買也可以啊
每個人幫我數 到底今天賺錢還賠錢
我是為了你們 給你們信心
馬上展停板 你告訴我哪有展停板
去年 所持展停板好像好幾年沒有了
這很誇張 這比重的 這應該跟熱透等級的
跟那個
大樂透
大樂透的機率更低啦
就是樂透等級的啦
是不是
一旦剛才你要長大分析室
買了以後閃停板
然後今天很多人說會跌
我說會拉紅
我說會拉起來
明天跌的機率比較高
所以你不要看這跌
沒有關係
重點是
上跪指數
來看一下
破底機率比較低了
所以如果明天真的有拉回
如果你想想看
你想看
你要買國具還是買環球金
還是買中衛金
你不知道你趕快來一洽詢
08068085好不好
反彈99妝案
好不好
隨時會結束
我頂多禮拜二禮拜三就要結束了
好不好
這跟大家講
我們最後看一下大家有沒有什麼反應
好不好
日傳千萬難忍
全人者者一在突破
謝謝大家
者者加油
愛者者
我也愛你們
好不好
OK嗎
笑到肚子痛
謝謝大家
就是要結束這一段
來來
財經節目
越兇越喜歡
很多人就喜歡敲桌子
莫名其妙
桌子到現在這個是什麼牌的
我們到時候要介紹一下
來來
笑死
三張式根本沒有人買啦
夜盤怎麼看
衝衝衝
我都聽不到 沒關係
志永剛好說了
志永我覺得
害你漏尿
我這樣子緊急漏尿
那不是我的問題
是你問題比較大
好不好
來
來 OK
好啦 這個不要看空單
空單不准很久了啦
好不好
不准很久了
今天空單口住多少
沒關係 不准很久了 好不好
來來
姊姊襯衫是訂製的嗎
有些襯衫是訂製
有些這一件
你知道嗎 不好意思
我身材太好的人
其實不需要怎麼訂製
襯衫跟西裝
都有訂製的 也有買的
這一件不用的
因為姊姊身材本來就不錯了
所以不需要訂製先
好 這件不是訂製的 謝謝
可是也不便宜啦
身材不是定的 不是不是
不好意思
身材好 可以不用
再臭屁啦
我不喜歡一直炫耀
來
來喔
技嘉 技嘉之後看
什麼零零什麼的
我組裝型ETF我沒興趣啦
九成到最後輸台灣50啦
只是反彈的時候
或強勢上場的時候
可以
可以買一下啦
那你不如買股票
你看國際有兩根斬定板
哪個被動型
哪個組裝型ETF有兩根斬定板
對不對 沒錯吧
沒錯
是啊
技嘉怎麼看
技嘉也沒什麼跌
技嘉已經算沒什麼跌
你也不要想那麼多啦好不好
技嘉沒展沒跌
技嘉太老了啦
真是老AI
這不動喔我也想換
我會上去
他上去又再考慮換
我再看你一陣子
看你一陣子
因為他真的
他滿看跌的你懂嗎
技嘉滿看跌的
可是再上去他再不動
我們找一種動能比較強大的
比較容易創新高好不好
去想想看
你要找什麼意思
我也愛你們啦好不好
我也愛你們
農資好不好
台股真的正很兇
找一個真的會懂
跳正胸舞的分析師
我真的懂政兴的時候
該怎麼幫你
好不好
所以最後我們要結束幾分了
49分
來啦
我們之後反彈
49分剛好結束啦
不要超過50分了
反彈99專案
隨時截止好不好
你去想看你要找那邊吃好不好
歡迎來一條群
080066885
或加爾賴私訊我
不論對我錯説説一切一切
預告在前面
哇
今天台灣股市真的反彈了
哇我們一堆股票展停板
國具展平板
中美金
中美金今天也展平板
沒時間講
中美金我也能看好
我也能看好
黃金金看好
我當然看好中美金
精彩也展平板
這麼多股票展平板
你還不加入者子的行列
趕快來下旬
08068085
或叫我來私信我
說這次好
會不會怎麼算
這次好
我要賺大錢
我捷徑我所能來幫你
賺大錢
謝謝各位
我愛你們
拜拜
与所推荐分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家